okay thanks i'm going to talk about
multi-dimensional virtual values and
second degree price discrimination it's
going to be about multi-dimensional
mechanism design and a framework that we
have to prove optimality of mechanisms
and at this point in the workshop I hope
I don't need to try hard to convince you
that multi-dimensional mechanism design
is hard it's complex both in terms of
the structure of the opto mechanisms
that least that you see and also
analytically and computationally
fortunately also this an excellent
sample of the approaches that you can
take to tackle this complexity during
this workshop so for example we saw
algorithms approximation algorithms like
what Matt and young talked about we
start characterizations like what
Christers talked about and also there is
another paper in the econ literature by
ocean shown a these characterizations
are very general and very strong since
that they can if you have a certificate
of optimality you can use it to prove
the optimality of your mechanism in very
very general settings but we don't have
a general methods to come up with these
certificates there is alternative models
how we can we change them all a little
bit to get more tractability from it
like what jeep talked about and when he
talked about your partners i'm going to
stick to our favorite Beijing setting
and present methods that we have to
prove optimality of mechanisms or simple
mechanisms so again we also discussed
this that very often the mechanisms that
our theory predict to be optimal are not
the mechanisms that we see in practice
that are wrong and it's good to have
general methodologies that you can go
look at your favorite market and your
favorite mechanism and see try to
explain why this mechanism is actually
the mechanism that we see by proving it
is optimal so in some sense we try to
rationalize mechanisms that we observe
out there in the world so let me give
you now a sampling of what kind of
simple
mechanisms I'm talking about placed on
examples the first one is what we all
know the single item monopolist seller
who is facing a single agent with
unknown values and Myerson and others
showed that a simple mechanism which is
just to post a price for the item
maximizing the X but your revenue of
that price is the optimum mechanism of
the class of all mechanisms that could
involve involve randomization
negotiation and everything else now let
me make this example one step more
complicated by saying that let's say
we're still having it will have a single
item to sell but there are two ways to
deliver it so let's say that you're
thinking of an online retailer like
Amazon you're buying something online
there are two options to deliver it
either amazon can use a express shipping
method to deliver this item to you as
fast as possible or uses standard
delivery method that's going to take
longer and let's say that the the buyer
has some value V for immediate delivery
and some v x theta where this data is a
discount factor for the delay delivery
let's just assume that this data is less
than one meaning that the buyer wants it
as soon as possible and also let's say
that there is no cost for either of
these two shipping methods now we want
to know what mechanism is optimal in
this setting and stokey first showed
that if theta is known if you know if
the seller exactly knows what this can
factor is and the only unknown is the
value for immediate delivery then you
might as well just post a price for
immediate delivery and never offered a
buyer the delay delivery which makes
sense right because we know theta we
know that by authors likes immediate
delivery more than the delay delivery so
if you want to maybe maximize revenue we
should maximize surplus so so give it
give the buyer the item that the or the
option that he likes more well are
surprisingly we know that this doesn't
hold in general so if the value and this
discount factor are coming jointly from
some distribution then a source was the
first one who noticed that you can do
more sophisticated mechanisms so for
example you can offer lotteries and
improve your revenue and ideal here is
that
now by offering your more sophisticated
menu of options you can partition the
buyers based on the preferences so some
buyers will buy immediate delivery
somebody's will buy lottery somebody's
will buy a delayed delivery and
essentially price discriminate so offers
offer people different prices and not
worry about these prices interfering
with each other too much I'm going to
stick with the task of proving that the
simple mechanism we talked about which
was only offering a price for immediate
delivery is optimal and in particular
we're going to show that if V and theta
are positively correlated I'm going to
make this precise later then the optimal
mechanism is to just offer a price for
immediate delivery again I'm going to
put make this formal later but for now
notice that if B and theta for example
are independent we can show that the
optimum mechanism is to only offer a DVD
delivery let's see example number three
it is the case that you are selling two
items now the wire has some value for
the bundle some valued times theta one
for only getting only item 1 and V times
some other theta 2 for getting only item
2 and again all I'm assuming so far is
that theta 1 i'd say that you are less
than one meaning that is free disposal
the buyer only wants more more stuff and
there's no cost then you can again go
through the same argument and maybe at
first conjecture that since the bundle
is a favorite outcome for the buyer
maybe you should only sell that we have
seen many examples in this workshop that
this is not true not surprisingly
anymore and we can do more sophisticated
stuff but again in this stuff you're
going to see that if both of these
parameters are positively correlated
with the value for the bundle then you
just post a price for the grand bundle
of items good so there are three
examples they're kind of similar kind of
different let's see first that they can
be unified in a single model so this is
your example single item we wanted to
show the post prices optimal Merson did
that already the example 2 was too way
to deliver we wanted to show that poster
price for
immediate delivery is optimal example
number three does two items three
outcomes and post the price for the
bundle is after so this is the model
this is all the model that we are going
to use today is that there is n outcomes
buyer has value v i4 outcome I this
profile of values is going to be coming
from some joint distribution and there
is a zero outcome for which the buyer
has no value and utility of the buyer is
a value for the outcome that the
mechanism chooses minus the payment so
let's see that we can fit all these
three examples in this model an example
number one there was only one outcome
that the buyer gets the item there was
one value that was coming from a
distribution in the second example there
were two ways to deliver there is a V
for immediate delivery a value for delay
delivery so there are two outcomes in
the example number three there were
three outcomes do you get the bundle do
you get either one only do you get item
to own good I know mechanism as we have
seen before is a menu of lotteries and
prices so a lawyer is just a
distribution over these end outcomes and
the zero outcome and is assigned a price
and the favorite mechanism that you want
to prove optimal this simple mechanism
that I'm talking about posts a single
price for the favorite out so this
mechanism becomes posted pricing for a
single item because the favorite outcome
among one outcomes is that the buyer
gets the item if I'm talking about this
case for the two outcomes were delayed
and immediate delivery the favorite
outcome was again and getting it
immediately the outcome the item and in
the case of two items were there were
three outcomes the favorite outcome was
again the bundle of items so just post
the price for demanding of items so if I
manage to prove this theorem we have
proved all these three yourselves
my favorite you need favorite of your
presence yes so the one that maximizes
VI good so this is outline of the talk
is also our contributions in this paper
first of all I'm going to describe to
you what are these conditions that I
talked about that imply optimality of
pricing posting your price for a
favorite outcome and then talking more
detail about the methodology that we
have on the proof technique and the nice
thing yes coordinated is highest is
always the same in-depth knowledge they
say for now that we know which outcome
is the favorite in my example that was
true the one of the outcomes was always
a favorite everything extends we can
talk about it later but list for this
dog let's just assume that it is known
which one is favorite yes it is uniquely
known no actually not unique but it's
favorite okay good so this methodology
that I keep talking about is just
generalizing the idea of designing
virtue value function for
multi-dimensional settings and as a
bonus of designing such a extending such
a well-known methodology to multi-agent
settings we can say even stuff about
multi-agent multi-parameter actual
mechanism so we can we can compare the
ribbon from different agents to okay
good so for the rest I'm going to do the
first one first task first which is to
talk about these conditions on what they
are okay so here is a picture that I'm
going to keep drawing so this is just
the possible pairs of values that the
agents can have for the items and again
as we said let's say that I'm showing a
high quality in a low quality item so we
know that the agent always likes the
high quality item at least more than the
low quality items so we're in the lower
triangle if you want a concrete example
keep thinking about immediate and
delayed delivery but in general and then
talk about high and low called good so
any point here is just a pair of values
for these two outcomes I'm going to
start with discussing a class of
instances which I call the perfectly
correlated class and what does that mean
it means that let's say we know types
are lined and a given curve so we have a
curve and we know that all possible
types are on this curve what can we say
about this example
let me first formalize how we discuss
how we explain such an example how we
represent it so I'm going to have to
talk about what the curve is and we're
under curve we are so let me just have a
distribution that tells us where and the
curve at type is and we have the curved
so here are the two not now I'm just not
going to assume that for now but in the
conditions of the theorem is going to
show up okay so so let's say that you
have a distribution F H which is a
marginal distribution of the high
quality value so we're on the x-axis
will I this is the what distribution of
H tells us in addition to represent the
curve I'm not going to do that the what
you would think at first I'm going to
instead assume that i have a function
theta of v that tells me what the
discount factor of a given VHP's so
given the discount factor i can
indirectly define the value for the low
quality item as being v value for the
high quality item times the discount
factor of this type okay so these two
functions are all I need to define an
instance in this class and it's going to
become clear in a second why I talked
about this theta function because all my
theorems are very nicely expressed in
terms of this function and in some way
this is the right way to look at this
problem so an example is that this theta
function the discount factor function is
just a constant so did we go back to the
case that we know exactly what the
discount factor is and my curve is just
going to look at this look like a
straight way out of 0 to theta okay good
again my question is is only pricing
posting a price P for the high quality
product the opto mechanism or not my
main theorem is going to be conditions
that implies that this is true before
seeing the main theorem let's see
another theorem that says when it is not
true that this mechanism is optimal and
here is it here if this function theta
decreases anywhere meaning that it's not
monotonic decreasing then there exists a
marginal distribution for a high quality
product that makes this instance jointly
defined by these two functions
the pricing not optimal for it okay so
let's see why this is the case so let's
look at any P at which this data goes
down so this Peter theta goes down
because if you look at the angle of the
line from 0 to P it went down as my
value increased so I came up with a pair
of values for which the theta the
discount factor of the high tide is nor
than the discount factor of a low type
so let's look at the any such p birthday
that goes down and I'm going to first of
all pick the distribution on marginal
distribution on high value such that if
I were going to post the price only for
the high quality product P would have
been the best price so pick any of your
any distribution that you like that
makes p the best price if you were going
to only post a price that's all I have
to do with F now I just want to care
about the curve and how it looks like
and what we are going to show is that
there is another mechanism that improves
revenue compared to just own only
posting the price P for the favorite
outcome and that is simply poster price
before a high-quality product also post
a price another price for the local
product what is that price the price is
how much this type would have paid for
the low quality product minus the tiny
discount minus ay epsilon okay so now
let's see what's going to happen i'm
going to argue that i'm going to claim
that this marginal change improves
revenue therefore showing that no posted
pricing mechanism could happen up so
let's see what happens as the result of
this change as a result of this change
the type space is going to be the
partition into three sets one sort of
the types who don't buy anything once
enough types who would have bite the
high quality product if the only offer
was p another still buying the high
quality product and some sort of types
who are now buying the low college
product so as a result of this change
there are there is a trade-off and how
much my revenue changes
in two different aspects one is that
there is this little set of types who
would have not bought anything if i was
going to only offer high quality at
price p and now they're buying the low
quality and pay me p x theta so this is
the gain from this change from that set
so it is how much they pay x what is the
probability that they show up there is
on the other hand a loss which is that
some types would i pay p now they're
paying this less the discounted price
this is the expected change in revenue
from them which is what is that change
in their payment times the probability
that they show up and the point is that
these probabilities depend on how long
is this size of this interval of the
projected curve under x axis and just
trust me this is just simple algebra
that you can use this property that
theta went down at P to show that this
marginal benefit is more than the
marginal gain therefore showing that
pika daughter could not have been
optimal good so next I'm going to show
my main theorem which is what are the
conditions that do imply posting a price
for how cold is optimal and I'm going to
straight ly define it for the general
class and not only for the perfectly
correlated class all right so what how
do I present the general instance I just
need a joint distribution on value for
high quality and the discount factor and
these two will define and directly the
value for low quality as the discount
factor times the value for high college
and the main theorem is so this is the
picture again you have be a high quality
and data and the main theorem is this
person card quality is optimal if value
for higher quality and theta are
positively correlated and the marginal
distribution of x is regular don't worry
too much about the second part we can
relax it the important thing is this
positive correlation of V and theta
so what is this positive correlation
formally it is positive correlation in
first-order stochastic dominant sense
meaning that let's say that you are
given the pH value for high code that
will imply a conditional distribution
for the discount factor the problems
which is a probability that given V H
what is the probability that your
discount factor is below a certain theta
let's fix trader and increase H and
increase vh and it says that this is not
increasing so it can only go down as V H
goes up meaning that probably that is
below some threshold goes up as village
goes up which is some form of positive
correlation right oh it's standard
first-order stochastic dominance let's
see what it what it says for our
perfectly correlated instance that i
described first so what does it say so
if I have a perfectly correlated
instance meaning that I have a curve I
know very simply what this conditional
distribution is if my curve is below the
Ray identified by theta I know that
theta is going to be less than this
given threshold so f of theta given V H
is one if the curve is below the Ray and
0 otherwise if this curve is a battery
so now this condition that this
conditional distribution is not
increasing in nvh implies that when i
look at my curve and connect array from
0 to any theta the curve must be below
the Ray before the point of connection
and above the Ray after the point of
correction connection so it's kind of
curving up some form of positive
correlation so this is the main this is
the corollary of the main theorem for
perfectly correlated innocence saying
that if this theta function is monotone
and f is regular pricing hi colt is
optimal let's compare that to the
theorem that you had before which was
when it is not optimal was saying that
if theta is not monotone then p is not
up so in this case we have actually
tight characterization of when
this is up if you want another story to
help you remember this main theorem
think about the high-quality product as
being the hard cover of a book that
you're selling and the low quality
product being the what is it a paperback
version of it and then this theorem says
that pricing only the high the hard copy
book is the option mechanism if serious
readers tend to not judge a book by it's
cover okay good so let me just show you
somewhere examples of a distribution
that satisfy this main condition the
first case as I said a special case of
positive correlation is independent so
we can have distribution that you draw
the theta independently from the H so
for example let's say that the
distribution of high-quality product is
uniform from 0 to 1 that is the
distribution of Thetas uniform
FrontPoint to 2.6 this is the picture
that you get this is domain after
distribution that you get is a trapezoid
it's going to keep being a trapezoid as
long as you start assume that the
distribution is uniform over a set as an
example that is not independent you can
pick any of the fader monotone curves
that I'd be talked about and distribute
the mass equal the above it this is
going to be also satisfying our positive
correlation property why let's see why
let's say we do fix any certain theta
and we see what's the probability that
given the certain vh the discount factor
falls below it and we see here that with
some positive probability it fell below
it and it went to 0 so it went down and
if you check it for all tailors you see
that it always goes down which is titus
very glad perfect what instance does not
satisfy this condition is this instance
so you have a triangle from point eight
to one and if you pick a certain theta
this data you will see that this
conditional distribution went from zero
to something positive as a change from
we want to beat you why do I care about
not allowing this instance in my class
because this was a
instant that we know the tennis always
showed that the pricing the high quality
product is not out so if I return is
correct it shouldn't follow my
characterization good so these are the
instances I the instances I talked about
are all for simplicity uniform
distributions over some set where we all
we cared about was the shape of the
domain but in general we don't assume
anything specifically about the domain
but it's only a condition on correlation
good now for rest of the talk i'm going
to talk about this proof methodology
that i mentioned before that is our main
terms again so this positive correlation
means that all in selling the
high-quality public is optimal it
extends very easily to multi-agent
settings so if each of the distribution
of each of the agents satisfy this
correlation property your multi-agent
optimal mechanism is just going to be
ignoring low quality products and just
assuming that it's your selling that one
high quality product then Madison tells
us what up doe mechanism should look
like so second prize we deserve if
they're identical and the more
complicated a mechanism on the marginal
distribution for the high quality
product if they're not identical but now
we can talk about the proof technique to
do that as I said you're going to extend
marstons theorem so let's let's see what
Marcin theorem was on how it was proven
Marcin showed that there exists a
virtual value function in fact a single
virtual value function that satisfies
two important properties that you're
going to extend one so this is the
virtual value function which are called
cut it going to call fee one is that the
revenue of any mechanism with allocation
function X can be represented as it's
expected virtual surface meaning the
expected x x 3 x / x is the probability
that a type v gets the item important
property number two is that if you look
at the allocation of the pricing
mechanism it in facts optimize optimizes
this virtual surplus point
twice we know if even if you relax all
the instead of compatibility constraints
so what do I need for for these to hold
that the idea pricing maximizes X time
fee it's enough that feels monitor so if
you have such a virtual value function
if I want to optimize X time free
subject to my allocation condition this
is what I get below when feels negative
i will set X to be as small as possible
when few is positive i'm going to save
it as big as possible and then we are
done by observing that this is an
allocation of a instead of compiler
mechanism it optimized surplus a point
wise and therefore an expectation and
buy this property it optimizes revenue
over all possible allocations now we're
going to extend this how are we going to
extend it by extending the integration
by parts lemma which is the key the key
step in Marstons derivation which use to
be able to express revenue in terms of x
times some form that you don't care
about but just mice and then call this
virtual value function fee and then rest
of the story so we're going to extend
this and this is how it extends I don't
expect you to understand why but let's
we're just going to focus on how to use
this lemma so this lemma is an extension
of integration by parts plus the
envelope theorem to high dimensional
settings and says that for any choice of
paths in this space so pick your
two-dimensional or even higher
dimensional space and cover it with a
certain selection of paths let's call
that alpha and any mechanism x you can
use a virtual value function that is
going to be implied by your choice of
paths again don't worry about how
exactly but any choice of Pat gives you
a virtual value function that satisfies
this property that the revenue of any
mechanism is equal to its expected
surplus the difference from here the
Martians result is that now we have to
be careful this is a vector this is a
two dimensional equation we are going to
also get a two-dimensional varsha value
function but the rest is similar just
not you want to maximize the dark
productivity of these two
functions so let's see some pictures
let's say that you can you can pick
these straight lines to cover your space
and then it will give you some virtual
value function if you pick other a
choice of pads to cover the space it
will give you some other virtual value
function let's see how we can use this I
have not told you what is the dependence
of alpha and fee but let's see how we
can use this idea number one is what
Armstrong did in 96 and said okay so let
me just pick some alpha let me just say
I pick straight lines and see what
virtual value function I get and then
see if I'm lucky if I actually can find
an allocation which is an allocation of
an incentive compatible mechanism that
point wise optimizes this then I'm done
right because I have proven that this
mechanism optimizes the surplus
point-wise therefore an expectation and
it's incentive compatible so we're done
so what we're going to do instead is
that we're going to start with the
mechanism and try to come up the bed
with the best choice of paths that prove
the optimality of that mechanism so we
start with the mechanism you look at
this allocation and then wonder what
kind of virtual value functions do I
need to design that this mechanism
point-wise optimizes if I write down
those conditions then I can worry about
the choice of paths that give me a
virtual value function that does satisfy
those conditions I'm going to go over
this methodology in the context of what
we talked about to prove the optimality
of only pricing the high quality product
and let's see how we can work it out so
this is the allocation of the mechanism
that I want to probe is optimal so there
is some threshold p above which the bar
gets the high quality product below
which it gets nothing now I want to
wonder what kind of virtual value
functions is optimized point wise by
this allocation i can write a bunch of
conditions right so i know that below
this threshold both of the components of
my virtual value function should be
negative which is what i need to
get a zero allocation and above which
the component of the high-quality
product must be positive and the other
component must be less than that it
could be negative or it could be
positive but must be less than the one
before the high quality product if I can
come up with this then my ex optimizes x
times so i write this down there is one
more step that now I can actually pin
down the virtual value of the high
quality product because notice that at
this point I'm assuming that like I'm
requiring that my virtual value for high
quality is going from negative to
positive so it must be zero on this line
so it must be not a function of what the
value for the low quality product is
let's impose this everywhere let's say
that the virtual value of the high
quality product is not a function of the
value for the low quality product how
this helps us is that it lets us extend
the result to multi-agent mechanisms
because if to virtualize for high
quality products are treated differently
based on the low quality then you cannot
just ignore the low quality product and
optimize surplus this lets us find the
form of the virtual value for the high
quality product now all you have to do
is to plug this into a dilemma that you
have which was integration by parts that
tells us what virtual value functions
are feasible based on some choice of
paths that turns out to be actually some
differential equation now that you have
one of the components turns out that
differential equation is solvable it
will spit out for you the other
component and all you have to check is
that this condition is satisfied which
is the local TV virtuality is less than
the high quality virtual and this is
exactly where the condition of the
distribution comes into play okay so to
recap our theorem is proved with coming
up with a choice of paths that imply a
virtual value function that satisfy two
properties one was that you can express
the revenue of any mechanism in terms of
its virtual surplus to was that your
mechanism optimizes virtual surplus
pointwise Myerson actually does this to
the the reason it the derivation becomes
simpler ease case
is that there is only one choice of
paths so you just integrate by parts and
then verify whether what you get is
inside of compatible or not there's no
choice of paths in a multi-dimensional
setting on the other hand there are many
choices of paths which is good news
because we know that there is also many
potentially optimum mechanisms so we can
use this choice of paths to come up with
the virtual value that proves the
optimality of the mechanisms that we are
looking for so many you have many
virtual value functions that satisfy the
first property you just have to use the
property of the mechanism that you want
to prove is optimal to come up with the
right one that satisfies both both both
of the properties okay so to conclude we
have a set of tools to prove optimality
of mechanisms in multi parameter
settings and we are going to be we do
this by constructing virtual body
functions that satisfy these two
properties that revenue is virtual
surplus and our desired allocation
optimizes it point wise and we
reverse-engineer the right virtual value
form based on the requirements that
impose on it there are many extensions
that I have not discussed I only talked
about two outcomes this generalizes very
easily to the case of many outcomes we
will relax regularity as I said it's
also ironing very similar to what
Madison does I didn't talk about costs
but we can have costs that you can
actually merge with the values or shoe
shift the values with the given costs
and then they become the problem becomes
a similar to assuming no costs there are
different favorite outcomes as Serge I
mentioned that the theorem easily
extends to the case that or it could be
different favorite outcomes the form of
the mechanism is just going to become
post a price for a favorite out and the
buyer can pick what outcome he wants
that's it thank
test so how does this set up to be
compared to do I'll be from like yeah so
I guess the difference is that there's
there's is as I said a certificate of a
penalty so it's and if and only if ours
is only implying the sufficient
conditions but it's more I think more
tractable because we have a methodology
to to coming up with it and the way
technique-wise the way they handle it is
that we have this revenue in terms of
utility and its gradient they get rid of
the gradient and write the problem in
terms of fertility we get you love
utility anti-riot in terms of gradients
which then becomes the allocation
function yes redefine the type to be so
you have the age and then you have a
independent variable from the age of the
turbines let's go get the HW and you
like the problem so assume the field
should live exactly so those are what we
call a quick one tall curve so exactly
exactly what you said so just come up
with some parameter that lets you this
entangle these two things together worry
about curves and then put them back
together exactly so yeah